brendan and cody congratulations you
guys are in the third and final round of
this competition now when you came here
we asked you to make smashes to very
exacting specifications well that's led
us up to our next and final challenge
where you'll have to forge this
parameter heavy blade from history
[Applause]
the spanish conquistador sword
good luck we'll see you in four
days good luck man
so it's day one we are in atascadero
california at my home forge and i'm
about to make a spanish conquistador
sword from adcrv2
and so it begins
no power hammer no press i am just gonna
be doing a lot of hammering today
it's got a lot of parameters on it's got
a knuckle guard medallion pommel a lot
of places that i could mess up
so at this point the end of day one i
moved a lot of metal and i did it
without a power hammer
my hand
doesn't really feel very good but it's
all good
it's the start of day three today's
gonna be all about the guard with all
these pieces on this guard the balance
and the weight of this is gonna be an
issue most of us just gonna be seeing
what feels right
i have to start bending up the quillians
and the knuckle bow
at first it was pretty confusing trying
to figure out which direction the swoops
of the quillians were supposed to go
as i broke it down it became clear in my
head
starting to look like something
i have a big chunk of damascus left over
from the blade that i plan on using for
the pommel and this will balance out the
weight of the sword
[Music]
i'm really happy with the way everything
came out so tomorrow will just be a
little bit of cleaning fine tuning and
shaping
day three
i have to finish this blade i gotta get
it heat treated i gotta get as much of
that done today as possible no i gotta
get all of that done today
as i'm forging this thing out i'm just
about done i'm straightening it and i
noticed that it's not quite getting as
hot
the propane's running out
it's just slowly dropping
it's not very easy to go fill this tank
at this point i am running out of time
so i'm not gonna quench today because i
won't be able to get the blade hot
enough
so i'm gonna just wait it out until i
have the propane get the even heat that
i need because there's zero room for
it's the start of day four i have to get
everything cleaned up i got to get the
handle shaped i will bet it with epoxy
i'm going to wax the tang and then pour
it into the handle and that will set
up i think i can afford to do a little
texturing it'll add a little bit of grip
everything slides on just as i want them
to
this thing
will heal
so it's day four last day i was able to
get some new propane in the tank i have
a big list of stuff to do today
so i'm quenching before i do anything
else
yeah it came out great
now i have to start thinking about all
the other components of this build
starting out with this guard
i'm actually welding it to the blade
because i won't have to worry about it
slipping off i think it'll be fine
i'm checking the specs and it says disc
shaped pommel it doesn't say that it has
to be steel so i think that my best bet
is just making one out of wood
it's over i'm tired i'm stoked that i
think i hit every parameter and i feel
extremely excited to see this thing in
action
all right bladesmiths welcome to the
kill test
your weapons are lovely but are they
deadly well to find out i will take your
weapon deliver some slashes and thrusts
on this beautiful spanish goat
cody you're up first you ready for this
i'm ready
all right cody i think there's a little
bit of a problem here
i can't get my eyes past the beauty of
the damascus that you have right here
this is a beautiful piece it cuts deeply
it thrusts nicely even when hitting bone
and it is a pleasure to wield during the
beautiful sword that you have here it
will kill
yeah
all right ben on your turn sir time to
have fun yeah let's do this
[Music]
good job
all right brandon let's talk about your
sword here your blade did take a little
bend here that wasn't there earlier the
handle kind of kicks up right now
now your edge is very sharp right here
the point is sharp enough to thrust all
the way using this edge delivers that
kind of cut
overall sir your weapon
it will kill
bladesmiths welcome to the perfect
strength test for your swords our flex
test
now properly heat-treated blade will
bend and come back to true if it's not
properly heat-treated it could bend stay
that way or just break all together cody
you ready to go
let's do it
[Music]
cody really nice job great balance
beautiful sword it hasn't moved at all
it's dead straight heat treating
damascus on a knife can be tricky enough
sometimes doing it on a sword like this
and keeping that heat treat dead on
really nice job thank you
all right brendan you saw what it's like
how you feeling
a little nervous
[Music]
[Music]
good job brenda yeah you could see when
it was locked in the vise
the guard was kicked off to the side so
you've got a twist in your blade up at
the tip you had a little bit of a warp
on the tip before
it's a little bit further now but not
extreme
good choice on the steels a little bit
of a bend but very good job
thanks
[Music]
all right bladesmiths now it's time to
find out how sharp your weapons are this
is the sharpness test divine slice
now conquistador or conquer in english
just just have to conquer their enemies
but the terrain that they find
themselves holding the weapon to find
out how sharp your weapons are i will
take your swords and try to cut through
these vines now unlike the strength this
is all about how well the edge of your
blade cuts to these vines cody up first
you ready for this let's do it
[Music]
all right cody we know from the keel
test the first four inches are sharp but
now for the sharpness test the rest of
the blade is very sharp like hot knife
through butter it will cut
all right brenda on your turn you ready
sir oh yeah
all right brent let's talk about your
edge here the first four inches here are
very sharp this razor edge right there
then it doesn't hold an edge on any of
this parts right here and then it picks
up a sharp edge in this area here
on that one vine that didn't cut there
is a laceration but not deep enough but
on the areas that are sharp
it cuts right through so
it will cut
all right bladesmiths the forged and
fire champion is
cody congratulations you're the new
force and fire champion good job brother
brendan unfortunately your blade didn't
make the cut come on forward my friend
it's excellent
this was a very difficult challenge
having such a complex final build to
make it was pretty crazy but it was a
great time
cody congratulations you are the fours
and fire champion and that's the title
that comes with the check for ten
thousand dollars good job my friend
i just won forge and fire this is
awesome this is the most money i've ever
had in one check that's for sure
i have no idea what i'm gonna do with
this money i'm gonna spend some of it on
my shop and i'm gonna spend some of it
on my family
you